hello jess how you doing shut up i don't
talk with you
oh i don't really recognize it i analyze
you because what a fatter thing ever
at least you look the same jess i mean
yeah you're looking great in red
look at debut look like a damn one i am
so glad i see
you part one of the tell-all
kicked off with insult after insult
they just kept coming it was like a
free-for-all
just say whatever you've been thinking
with no type of filter
i don't recognize her what's going on
people may say but she's like
michael jackson 3.0 you know what i mean
at least i have a job
now andre asked for that one
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
the happily ever after season five cast
came together in one room or should i
say zoom
and so many of our big questions were
answered
we learned that colt has not been honest
about his sexual relationship with
vanessa jess i love i lied to you about
vanessa
okay whoa
what kalani and i swallow revealed
where their marriage stands
here he goes this is what he does right
now and now
i clearly understand why jen and charlie
were
so upset about elizabeth and andre's
moldovan wedding
charlie did he pay for your wedding no
no he didn't pay for mine either
so bye and that's just the tip
of the iceberg well the entire episode
wasn't all about the tough questions
the couples also took a look back at the
special moments
that happened throughout the season for
angela
reliving her wedding to michael brought
her to tears
[Music]
i'll tell you exactly why in just a few
but first let's get into cole who
revealed that his sexual relationship
with vanessa continued after he broke up
with jess colt did you and vanessa
have a sexual relationship yeah
no uh i know vanessa was it's just my
friend
i'm sorry let me no no your life lie to
people you're narcissist
uh-huh jess i love i lied to you about
vanessa
before i met you jess we had we slept
together
of course and then after we broke up i
slept with
her some more i just can't get over the
fact that when shawn
first asked the question cole and debbie
continued on with the lie no
uh i know vanessa was just my friend
and then all of a sudden he decided to
tell the truth
well you know what folks next week we're
hearing straight
from vanessa cold while you were in a
relationship
with jess did you and vanessa sleep
together do you have
no mothers vanessa just discovered this
water because still light people
disgusted says the girl calling me a
virgin
yup yo i have so many thoughts right now
that i'm just going to keep to myself
okay moving on kalani and asuelu
revealed that they are
still together but it's complicated
what is the status of your relationship
today
um today we are
together and we're living together
but we aren't anywhere near where we
used to be when we reversed together
we're just like in a really rocky place
right now kalani said that
after she sent asuelu away to his mom's
house for
not following quarantine guidelines he
invited himself back
without telling her and to add on to
that he is still
doing the exact same thing that made her
kick him out in the first place
what are the things that you keep
arguing about
we give our care of me go play
volleyball
and go my brex dance practice
and why do you guys argue about playing
volleyball
um guess i'm not going
to play whiteboard for one day i'm going
to play wonderful like
except sunday every day except sunday
okay in the middle of the pandemic
right that's a lot yeah and he told me
oh yeah i'm wearing a mask and then he
would accidentally send me videos
of him playing without a mask so that
i'm like okay you're lying about even
being careful i'm not sure how kalani
does it
at this point asuelu is not only putting
her and the babies at risk
but he's also putting her mother at risk
as well
during the tell-all her mother revealed
that she has a pre-existing heart
condition
and they all live together i gotta say
you have to be very concerned about your
son-in-law lisa going out every day
and playing sports around a lot of
people how do you feel about it
i feel like it's irresponsible
he's irresponsible period he wants to do
what he wants to do
period he doesn't care about anybody
else but himself
period when someone says period that
much
you know they mean it actions speak
louder than words
and based off of asuelu's actions
kalani's mom
and sister doubt that this relationship
will last much longer i mean they're
sitting together right now
do i see them together in the future
i don't at this point in time
uh lisa do you think the same
i know my daughter and unless
he's going to start changing like he
expects everyone else to change for him
it's not going to last she's not going
to put up with her stuff there's no way
aswella was even asked about
disrespecting kalani
and calling her out of her name during
their family road trip
here was his response it's hard it's
hard to figure out
it's called a conversation not
everything has to be combative it
doesn't have to
get into you calling my sister a [ __ ]
you don't have to feel attacked every
time someone points something out
okay say to her she's a [ __ ]
here he goes this is what he does i know
all right moving on to angela and why
taking a look back at her wedding to
michael
god are so emotional the reason why she
got so emotional
because of a rich mom and uh she
wishes the mom was present the
in the wedding hey angela i'm sorry
no need to apologize at all i just
thought of
all of a sudden don't apologize don't
ever apologize for feeling it
i think she'd have been proud oh yeah
definitely
so happy for you guys now just a little
bit longer you'll be together
yeah she's really craving that face to
face affection and support from michael
right now
and if you're wondering why angela has
on a mask
it has nothing to do with the pandemic i
have um
some dental work get ready go on and i
got an abscess
oh my goodness yeah i have to keep it
covered so the air will get in and make
it worse
it's pretty bad i understand all right
finally
elizabeth's brother charlie admitted to
being
embarrassed after watching the way he
handled himself
at elizabeth and andre's moldovan
wedding that was embarrassing
what do you have to say for yourself
charlie i have way too much to drink
and you know i was
i was pretty out of line so charlie when
andre was drunk uh and he was saying
things you said that that alcohol
brought out the truth is the case the
same
for you
yeah liquid courage even after like all
the stuff my dad's done for him
you know he's still like you know
disrespectful
while andre has been a stay-at-home dad
chuck
has been spending his money taking care
of elizabeth and andre's
household we're at a wedding we're
supposed to have a good time
well they're already married
and you're still paying for them pay
their rent
[Music]
so during the tell-all chuck was asked
does he think he's being taken advantage
of by andre
i would hope not you know because what i
do for my family is out of love
you know and i want to see them be
successful in life any any parent wants
that for their kids
i just i don't want to believe that
because that would really crush me
dad what are you talking about you saw
what he did as far as telling libby to
go ask you for money for the wedding
that's a tradition jen he has to pay for
the wedding because he paid for our kids
weddings
andre that's not all true elizabeth's
sister jin
also revealed some interesting
information
chuck let me ask you something how many
weddings have you paid for
uh well two three
four four i paid for
no you didn't pay for my wedding you
paid for three which few weddings were
you talking about
paid for becky he paid for libby's first
one and he paid for
their third one charlie did he pay for
your wedding
no no he didn't pay for mine either so
bye
all of the shade they were throwing in
moldova makes even more sense now
all right well next week on part two of
the tell-all
asuelu sister tammy gets asked about
trying to fight
kalani i was shocked you really wanted
to fight
kalani because she was starting to walk
away why would she stand there and take
that from the both of you
fellini why you had to be involved i
would beat up galani and beat you up now
you want to fight me fight me
don't tell me what to do don't tell me
what to do
and tanya and sinjin get in the hot seat
andrew and james what do you think the
problem is tanya
i will not be giving up drinking
probably my whole entire life
and if that bug's hurt that just means i
must get somebody who doesn't have an
alcoholic
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i'll see
you next time